the Sony hack arm is a very interesting
phenomenon I I think it's sort of it
brings home some of the issues that
people in other countries face the way
for example North Koreans have hacked
South Korea and South Korean financial
institutions and Russians have hacked
Ukrainian and Estonian institutions the
whole notion of cyber conflict either as
a low level or high-level conflict has
become more and more important than more
and more top of mind and I think the
most important takeaway is twofold one
is that quote unquote ordinary citizens
should be concerned about whether their
data assets and that includes everything
from their social security numbers to
their bank accounts to the way their
mortgage is held they should be
concerned about how adequately protected
that is but not just and this is
important not just by the financial
institution or the retail institution
but by government to what extent is
protecting American data assets in the
US and abroad the obligation and the
duty of the government how well
protected are we in that regard I
believe this is a policy and a question
of great not just national import a
global import because America is a
leading nation both in terms of
Technology and in terms of vulnerability
and it raises important questions about
what constitutes self-defense in this
regard do we run into the situation that
we just say well this is a crime so
we'll just have the FBI and law
enforcement handle it or is it something
else and you know I'm not a lawyer nor
do I care to be one but I think we want
to be really really really really really
careful about saying something oh it's
just an act of vandalism or oh it's just
a misdemeanor when in fact it's more
threatening than that and it may it we
may be hurting the safety and security
of our citizens by minimizing the kind
of threats that are involved here one
last thing I'm going to say here is
there is an analogy here for those of
those people familiar with policing of
the famous broken windows argument which
is you know it's a low-level crime
ignore it and that you know and and
crime rates began to drop when we
stopped ignoring seemingly minor
infractions of the law when we invested
as a society in norms that demanded
something other than the absence of you
know just ignoring things of the margin
but demanding respect for the law and
this in my view this is as true outside
of the borders of the United States as
it is inside the border of the United
States and it's particularly true when
people come across the border of the
United States to destroy to destroy
vandalize ation is a cute word to
destroy the assets of Americans in the
United States not cool